[Musique]
jour j celui où les enfants passent la
porte de l'école pour la dernière fois
de l'année un moment qu'on savoure avec
délice
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'eux des jours de
place dans sa muse et puis orange la
classe
wow film deuxième marcquois maintenant
bah là on va les sécheresses et
l'inauguration de la fresque des
semaines de travail consacré
officiellement le dernier jour de
l'année les élèves ont réalisé tout seul
la fresque elles représentent des contes
de fées
[Musique]
des contes de fées à la danse il n'y a
qu'un pas on est vite franchi
[Musique]
des tirs on range nous payait tout
madame elle ramasse mélissa la batmobile
écolo parce que moi génial à la mer les
vacances c'est vraiment génial
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]